[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la
presencia de la variante del talco bit
19 en buena parte del continente
americano inquieta a las autoridades de
la región y a organismos internacionales
la ms ha dicho que es la más
transmisible que se conoce hasta ahora y
por ende es una de las que despierta
mayores preocupaciones para hablar sobre
este tema nos acompaña ya como es
costumbre de todos los jueves el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
además asesor científico de france24
doctor gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france24 comencemos por
entender la transmisibilidad los cdc de
eeuu han dicho que la variante delta es
tan contagioso a comenzar ampeón o la
varicela qué tan grave es esto que
caracteriza la variante delta
esta variante es una variante que tiene
la característica en una alta carga
viral es decir la gran presencia de
virus en el tracto superior respiratorio
y de ahí su transmisibilidad lo que
conocíamos es que una persona enferma
infectaba a dos personas y la variante
delta infecta una persona entre cinco y
ocho personas
esa gran transmisibilidad hace que sea
similar al comportamiento de la varicela
y su contagiosidad sea muy importante
ahora doctor también se ha trascendido
que en los tests de la variante delta es
más susceptible a arrojar falsos
negativos esto es así y de ser así que
recomienda a la población
no realmente los tests son falsos
negativos si no se toman con un criterio
clínico y en un tiempo esperado
generalmente la presencia de síntomas
indica la tomada de la muestra y en el
contacto entre el tercero a quinto día
es donde máximo el examen tiene mejor
rendimiento entonces y lo de los falsos
negativos probablemente tiene que ver es
con la pre apresurarse martí los
resultados o inter previos a
inadecuadamente si hay síntomas
respiratorios hay que pensar que están
hacer el examen doctor y dentro del
continente americano cuáles son las
zonas más preocupantes
se demostró básicamente la circulación
en colombia pero en algunos países de
américa latina se presume su que está
contagiando a las personas pero no hay
esta vigilancia genómica que es distinta
a la que hacemos tradicionalmente porque
requiere más tecnología y todo es
incierto lo que decía es muy probable
que en un par de semanas cuatro o seis
semanas ya sea predominante en algunos
países de la región y en colombia ya se
está determinando su presencia y es que
a eso quería ir en américa latina
todavía la variante no es el
predominante pero ya brasil uruguay hay
una transmisión comunitaria estamos de
alguna manera ante un escenario similar
que atravesó la región en la peor ola de
la pandemia hasta ahora
va a depender mucho de nuestro
comportamiento de la tasa de vacunación
nosotros tenemos en varios países un
rezago en la vacunación ninguno de los
países ha logrado llegar a 40 ó 50 por
ciento de la población lo que nos hace
inferir que definitivamente va a haber
una cuarta ola y puede ser por esta
variante de ahí que las medidas de
precaución y alejamiento físico use
tapabocas e higiene sigan siendo
importantes y tal vez son mucho más
importantes ahora porque evita esa
transmisibilidad de esta variante tan
contagiosa ahora doctor ya se empezó a
hablar de las terceras dosis para hacer
frente a esta variante a las personas
primero más vulnerables y también a
adultos mayores pero desde la oms se
pidieron una moratoria para que se
avance en la vacunación de la población
creció que todavía no ha recibido la
inoculación cuál es su postura frente a
esto
la vacunación debe completarse primero
en toda la población antes de pensar en
una tercera dosis nosotros tenemos un
tres cuartas partes de nuestra región
desprovista de vacunación sin la
vacunación no se hace masiva y
rápidamente las terceras dosis también
pueden fracasar por eso primero se debe
completar la vacunación hacer todos los
esfuerzos para la accesibilidad las
vacunas y luego contemplar las terceras
dosis sobre todo en poblaciones
especiales inicialmente estas decisiones
doctor de los países desarrollados
afectarían a la dotación de vacunas a
los países más pobres
sin duda lo que hemos visto es una
simetría y tenemos que entender que la
inmunidad colectiva se logra no
vacunando algunos sino va dándonos todos
personas que estén susceptibles en
cualquier país deben tener acceso a las
vacunas y por eso es tan importante que
se reforcemos la pauta completa para tu
doctor gracias por su tiempo y por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un buen día a usted también
gracias por siempre acompañarnos aquí en
nuestro canal
[Música]